dude let me tell you something when you
when you die you're God's pizza maker
you're going to make the pizza for
[Music]
God located in Carol Gardens Brooklyn
lucali is one of the most celebrated
pizzerias in New York City if not the
world the story of lucali is the stuff
of Legend and its enigmatic owner Mark
aono has become a larger than life
figure in the Brooklyn pizza scene but
to me Mark is a mentor a trusted
Confidant and a friend in 2020 Mark
offered me the chance to host a popup at
lucali launching my career in pizza and
changing my life forever today Mark has
agreed to treat me to an ultra rare VIP
experience at lucali teaching me and the
comedian Christa Stephano the secrets
behind his critically acclaimed pizza
but first i'm meeting Mark and my friend
Scott weiner in lucali's backyard to
hear about Mark's relationship with the
late Dom DeMarco of the farest and how
he went from Carol Garden construction
worker to one of the most legendary
Pizza makers on the
planet so Mark thanks for having us in
the most coveted backyard in Brooklyn
you never let me back here before you
know that no yeah my first time back
here well when you come here this is
where I hide well this is where you hide
I would here too tell them I'm not here
I would hide here all the time where do
you put the tables back here I don't
like I says it's these chairs we just
sit you know friends come back here
after they're done eating you know have
a glass of wine at the end of the night
and relax so I didn't want to come
empty-handed so I brought us Zara Oh
weird I was wondering what was in there
I smelled it I knew it right away so
this piece is from the legendary daaras
owned by Don DeMarco rest in peace to D
and I'm so honored that we get to share
this together here's the backyard and
here's the d o yep perfect the
D
the darara pie is so interesting because
it doesn't look perfect ever it's not
perfectly round it's not perfectly
cheesed to Sauce ratio nothing but it's
so perfect in taste tomato sauce on this
p is unbelievable yeah so mark what was
it like eating at the fars for the first
time and how did Don's Pizza influence
your own he's the guy that kind of took
New York style pizza to the next level I
had a friend who turned me on to Dom's
place and he was like you got to go you
got to go and I was like yeah all right
watch it's another New York life stram I
never forget like that first bite it was
a WTF moment for me and I was like wow
the first time I had this pizza was
probably about 6 months before I opened
here and I was trying to you know create
a pie but he was just so stuck in my
[Music]
head hi my name is Maggie melis I am the
owner of defar Pizzeria and my dad was
Dominic DeMarco my dad was the greatest
not just at cooking and making pizza but
he was the greatest father people would
say to this day and will continue
forever to say he was an artist his love
for what he did became known not just in
Brooklyn not just in New York not just
in the US but in the whole world a lot
of people are surprised to learn that
the way we make the pizza at Zara is we
make the pizza dough throughout the day
we do everything in small batches for
example when we make out tomato sauce we
hand squeeze the tomatoes in a small pot
that is the best way for it to remain
consistent I used to think my father was
crazy with that but he was brilliant
what I notice the most about a lot of
the pizzer is is a lot of them snipping
the fresh basil on the pizza just like
my dad did Mark from lucali has such a
tremendous respect and love for my
father and that showed any time they
would be in the same room together my
father father liked Mark a lot because
he can see that Mark had a certain
passion for what he does and he's great
at it and Mark he really really looked
up to my father to this day he speaks to
my dad and it's nice for me cuz that's
what keeps him with
[Music]
us I've heard the story time and time
again you know that you're a Brooklyn
staple a pizza Legend but why why did
you open lucali like why a couple coffee
I went out for a cup of coffee Saturday
afternoon I mean everyone knows this
location was a place I frequented as a
child my parents came here when they
were kids candy shop yeah yeah it was
closing down I bumped into Rosemary you
know at the coffee shop she was with all
her friends you know Louis had passed
away and they were going to rent the
space out and she told me and I like you
know I felt horrible you know this is a
place I grew up in and that was it you
know I got my coffee I said goodbye and
I just stopped dead in my
tracks and I was like you know what I'm
going to ask
and 2 Days Later signing a lease with
$5,000 to my name not knowing what I'm
going to do here and I was like you know
what I'm I'm going to do pizza the place
was gutted out and I just sit in a chair
and think how do I do it what am I going
to do how do I make it look how do I lay
it out I was digging through dumpsters
for wood and you know like I'd go to
construction sites and see what I could
take off the SES and no really I
believeit and that was it the place was
done and now I'm standing in here one
day and I'm like wow this place is
really nice I just got to figure out how
to make pizza
now this one here of me and Dom first
photo of two of us together I had long
hair back then I know I
see I want to see you like that grow out
this is one of my favorite pieces course
I remember coming here as a kid and like
I remember always seeing this Dutch yeah
right the cigar counter was down there
and it was right next to the candy
station and I always remember seeing it
and then like you know over over the
years it was gone never to be seen again
and and then while I was in here working
on the location I went downstairs and we
had a bunch of stuff stit down there and
I remembered it as a kid and gu I threw
that up
there we can't be at lucali without
talking about the oven and you actually
built this oven right yes what happened
was I designed the oven uh-huh but I had
to have someone make it but as far as
the design went and the shape of it it
totally totally against the Green like I
insisted on I was like this is what I
want he's like all right if that's what
you want I'll make it you know and
apparently it's wrong like what's wrong
about it it's you know usually see these
ovens from M like they're these big does
and yeah this one isn't this has four
walls and then just the roof is Dom one
way so he kind of like sent me all the
parts and I put it
[Music]
together you weren't a pizza guy before
you didn't come from a family of
Pizzeria owners came out of nowhere how
a friend of mine owned the pizzeria on
Court Street and he just so happened to
be closing as I was opening old man Joe
him and his son Lenny they had
Leonardo's Pizzeria and he came and he
just showed me the basics and I just
basically you know took what they showed
me and it just morphed into what it is
today one night you know I'm making
pizzas and and the dough is not
stretching here I am standing there the
orders are backing up and I saw a wine
bottle and I just grabbed it and I
started using that and everyone was like
oh he's us look at that he's rolling out
with a wit and then the pizza coolest
move ever and then I was like wow the
pizza's coming out real even better you
know so what makes the lucali pie so
special to you so first of all the pizza
to me is like a bridge between the old
school classic pre-1950s Brick Oven
Pizza of New York and the slice shop
Pizza it's really like a missing link
between those two the thing about the
lucali pie is that just like the darara
pie it's like it shouldn't be that great
and I'll tell you why I say that because
he pulls out this wine bottle he bashes
out all the gas from fermentation
flattens out the edge academically like
on paper it shouldn't be as good as it
is but it's great and I think that's a
beautiful thing about pizza which that
all the nerdy stuff aside it doesn't
mean it's going to taste good and more
important than that does mean it's going
to feel good to eat it this is why
people fly here from all over the place
it's not because they want to bump in a
Beyonce and
[Music]
JayZ 3 years ago today today on this
very date you offered me your space here
to do a popup I want to tell you that I
love you and I'm so proud to learn from
the greatest you know I didn't I never
thought in a million years it was going
to turn into what it turned into today
it's like every morning I wake up I wake
pinch myself it's crazy okay so I have
the comedian Christ Stephanos stopping
by I told him that you were going to
teach us how to make an authentic lucali
pie will you do that for us
[Applause]
[Music]
absolutely all right Nicole and Chris
you guys ready yeah how to make pizza L
Calli style okay amazing have you ever
made pizza before I've never made
anything at all all right you know what
let me let me tell you smell good Mark
by the
way you're a man you smell like pizza
and
cigarettes I just had one You' been here
before I've been here before I was here
once my wife said we were here twice but
she must have been here with her
ex or maybe current or maybe the man
she's having an affair with I have no
idea it doesn't matter anymore Mark I'm
here with you and that's the main thing
do I snort this no but but he wrote a
real nasty yel review when
no it wasn't me all right you got your
dough I got my dough Focus
sorry you ready so first we're going to
start like just with the fingertips like
flattening the dough out a little a
little harder yeah you're a little
focked hold on let me turn it for you
circles like push it into a circle push
it into it okay so make don't make it
look so make it look like a fock no no
oh okay you got a wine bottle right hold
on to that relax don't do anything yet
you're going to place the bottom the
center and push out and then kind of you
kind of want to put your fingers in here
oh yeah yeah all right no I'm just okay
who's that Mom guys remember
Frankenstein sorry I got to be honest
with you Mark it's too hard I can't
finger the bottle and do this it's one
or the other done Bang all right now
we're going to set these on the side
okay set them on the side we're going to
let them relax a little oh so you got to
relax and chill out yeah let him chill
let him relax we'll have a glass of wine
and we'll come back in a little bit and
pizza let's do it man I'm a recovering
alcoholic I'm ready to break the
sobriety right here ready to flush the
life down the toilet at lucali's I feel
like when other people from other cities
or other countries come to New York they
can walk into any random Pizzeria get a
slice and they be like oh my God this is
amazing but if they walked into lucali's
and they ate that they would they would
maybe they would kill themselves they
would they would it would be so amazing
they'd be like you know what what's the
point of life I just had the best thing
you just told me not to trip over it you
tripped over I didn't trip oh sorry when
you started this out too Mark you didn't
know that this was going to be what it
became you were like I'm just opening up
a pizza shop it's either this or witness
protection
yeah you keep it simple that's why I
think you have success it's just very
very simple all right so I just stretch
the edges hand over hand okay right and
just give a little stretch right don't
pick the dough up off the table Yeah
hand over this is like um cathartic it's
like it's like meditation a little bit
yeah watch me look hand over hand do you
like me you're a very nice guy thank you
I appreciate it cuz I'm getting good
vibes from you and Nicole all right but
you're picking it up off the table my
hand yeah see about that it's all good
don't worry I extra okay than I'm going
to take this guy I yeah I put a big hole
you're going to finish up this guy this
is a low moisture mozzarel we're going
to put the sauce this one and then after
that we're going to put the buffalo on
okay you ready yes you're going to take
a ladle of sauce right okay you're going
to drop that Ladle that Center look at
that look at that perfect you got this
you got this right in the center the
whole thing the whole thing there it is
look at this it looks like my small
intestine all right put the ladle away
grab some cheese and just thought like
you know it rain Make it oh okay make it
rain Make It Rain this here it is just
no Rhyme or Reason just get it on there
oh exactly yeah crack this in half crack
it right in half yeah and just break off
little pieces okay just a little bit
thanks yeah little pieces you know the
game fmk no never heard of it [__] Mary
kill [__] Mary kill Sauce Cheese
dough what is he talking about you got
to [__] one you got to marry one you got
to kill one Sauce Cheese dough I'm not
playing this
game well folks listen your Pie's ready
to go in the oven okay so you just shake
it off a little bit Yeah you give it a
little shimmy that Nicole swirl life
swirl life he's not gonna like the way I
swirl this out no I think that's a good
swirl you do you know what you getting
sick of Mark's criticism actually hey
get sick of his [__] keep it up I'm
going to burn your
P one of the things that's different
about doing it the lucali way when you
slice the cheese this way the Melt is
more even mark is really smart with
doing it this way that wasn't me that
was all D it was all D well he's smart
oh look at that oh huh I feel confident
and I'm kind of ready after just doing
this one time to open up right across
the street and give him a run for his
business I think I'm going to open up my
own Pizzeria don't do that I feel good
in here dude I want to just I want to
just [__] just start throwing cash at
people I want to start let's [__] run
a bookie business me and you mark let's
I want to do I'm out and you've had
never had a customer complain right
can't make had someone uh in here from
Chicago was his name Sean
Evans why don't we just do City Wars why
don't we [__] invade Chicago let's
get zinski to represent us and we go in
there he's at everybody's college
graduation we could get him you think
zinski is ever been here oh look at that
I mean this dude is a
legend that's good this is like dude let
me tell you something when you when you
die you're going to you're God's pizza
maker you're going to make the pizza for
God this pizza truly people say it's
number one in New York and if it's
number one in New York it's number one
in the country and then in United States
we're number one in the world it's
number one in the world this to me is
the number one pizza in the world so
guys this was so fun Chris thanks for
making pizza with us Mark you know I
love you and thank you so much for
hanging out with us today thank you for
having me on the show every time I come
in here I just get so nostalgic of our
time and how much you've done for me and
I just want to tell you thank you thank
you thank you and I love you love you
love you I love you more give him a kiss
earlier if you don't do it I
will
[Music]
oh